path americans believe in conspiracy
theories I love
this story region think that study
suggests that around 50 percent American
subscribe to at least one conspiracy
theory
this info is coming from NPR's social
science corresponded
Shekhar bend and damned if I pronounce
that right you guys who deftly NPR
people:
no I think I think I was closed from
NPR's morning addition
let's look at the findings with that so
nineteen percent of Americans believe
the US
government was behind the 9/11 attack
that seems incredibly high to me so the
fact that effect a 25 percent believe
the recent financial crisis
was caused by a smoke a bow on Wall
Street bankers who
and here's a good one 11 percent believe
the government is mandating the switched
to compact fluorescent light bulbs
because the white bold make people
obedient
an easy to control now I will play the
rational person here for one second
Carl Sagan said extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence that's
generally how I think about these things
I although I probably I have no problem
with aliens and predator alien for being
here in a minute later get
arm the nineteen percent on 9/11 seems
really high to me
where you think alright alright YouTube
commenters that probably very well
I we do remain yeah I do I believe that
numbered or do I think that do they just
seem high that that one out of five
Americans would would believe that it
was
that at the time like when you think
about it rationally would actually seems
low and you think that you know
in a in a moment sheer panic and
helplessness you know
in in times like that but part of our
brain you make the love that's the fear
center goes into or
it in the brain and analytical overdrive
for her and it leads to ask for coming
up with these narratives and help us
better explain the circumstances would
resist
so out of the ordinary and so you know
so fearful and
I think that we're fence mechanism that
in a way in a country where the same
people believe what they hear on Fox
News nothing surprising
I bring to you tho I mean think about
conspiracy theories is that
I you know a.m. it's not like
the government is so sure that we can't
ever believe the area but
you know they we didn't put smallpox in
blankets and give it to the native
americans i mean
it's not like word that the US
government is incapable love shenanigans
so
its not burn the hardest thing to
believe that americans are happening in
America don't forget the coalition
etiquette with that makes me i mean we
do something dies a lot of drugs that
are making people
you know peace in this country and so
you know it corn corn corn growers why
there why the government wants makes it
is making it difficult for you know
Tesla to sell cars because the oil
companies are paying them to do it you
know
so why not then think that maybe the CIA
decided to kill John F Kennedy or
something i mean you know
olexson so let's talk about the floor of
my building cuz I think that was the
meeting to 11 percent saying that these
new government mandated
libeled the light is actually a way of
controlling you
they had what do you think therefore I
like to be a big help for us that lie to
my high school and nobody was being
controlled so I am NOT buying now on
that that that to me seems like a
fluoride in the water kind of
right you know John Birdsall working as
I don't know the real you any research
from a4a
I don't know I mean I i can only you
know told you know love my personal
experience under fluorescent light have
always felt like a little more anxious
really are yeah really a babysit look
weird they're not flattering those for
us
Laura interesting so by peel weird what
do you mean by that
well i just i you know it's it's and the
lighting is never
good summer you know comfortable you
know as a kid I never really liked being
under that sort of false life Ronald
artificial
yet another that we're going home
they're the there's also an audible
component to a fluorescent light and I
don't
yeah I have like a home that no I think
says people
like tape hiss almost you know it's got
this like really sorta you know
subtle effect on your subconscious but
out and I'm answer it's a pretty crazy
idea that the government will be trying
to clear all that though is that the
beauty of conspiracy theories you don't
have to prove any of them so it's like
that
which one to believe in something like
the alien stuff obviously have no proof
I've it but it also it also fueled good
to think that you're you know in a
Vienna pack up she put your to walk but
her idea you're not being followed up
track do you guys have one that you
subscribe to a guess maybe the day okay
thing for your
know it for the CIA I I feel like
there's more the JFK
thing then we're being told that but I
don't know what it is
I haven't done the research with and I
saw the oliver stone movie many times I
ID again
a down we I'm not into conspiracy
theories
a not no nothing nothin now
alright but we know for a fact the bush
wanted to invade Iraq
the second he entered office and that
actually that's not a concern that their
covers that the thing that we know now
also that without the kind of thing that
makes conspiracy theories believable
look at ending a conspiracy theory
segment with the fact that is found it